foreign
ladies and gentlemen esteemed faculty
members distinguished tests
most importantly graduating class of
Purdue University in association with
simply learn welcome to the online
convocation ceremony
Today We Gather virtually to celebrate
your remarkable achievements
and uncertainties that have marked this
journey each and every one of you has
shown resilience determination and an
unwavering commitment to your education
we are immensely proud of your
accomplishments
while we may not be physically together
the spirit of this momentum occasion
remains as strong as ever
we are honored to have you join us from
different parts of the world
my name is Anjali mithil hosting this
convocation ceremony with my colleague
mohini singer
as we commence this online convocation
let us take a moment to reflect on the
significance of this milestone in your
lives
as we reflect upon The Incredible
Journey each graduate has impact upon we
recognize the countless hours of hard
work dedication sacrifices that have led
to this very moment
you all have overcome challenges both
personal and academic to reach this
milestone in your lives today we honor
your hard work sacrifice and unwavering
dedication
now I would like to invite Professor
bhart police
Professor is the director of the
graduate program at the renowned Brian
Lamb School
under his guidance the program has
flourished hampering campus-based
Masters and PhD program as well as the
esteemed online master of science in
communication program
Professor Bath's research interests are
focused on two crucial areas health
communication and Science examination
he has served as a faculty scholar in
the prestigious
real Steve Center for healthcare
engineering further highlighting his
commitment to Bridging the Gap between
Academia and practical applications in
the field of healthcare
we request the professor to address the
graduating class with a word of wisdom
and inspiration
over to you professor
thank you uh Anjali for that
introduction and uh very generous and
I'm very excited to be here I hope
everyone can hear me okay this is one of
uh uh the most exciting events uh that I
get to attend I've I've had the pleasure
of teaching several Masters uh classes
uh through this uh exciting
collaboration over the last uh couple of
years but but really uh getting a chance
to address people who've actually
completed their programs and and like
Ansley said uh dedicated a significant
amount of time and energy and resources
to furthering their education is
particularly exciting and I'm just happy
to be included in this event
um
one of the things I like to think about
at events like this is sort of what do
you do moving forward
um and how do you sort of think about
the use of what you've learned as you
progress through your your professional
careers and Purdue likes to Define their
mission uh as an institution of higher
education and really three three ways uh
that that we call Discovery learning and
engagement I'd like to just spend a
moment talking about these certainly
Discovery represents our our commitment
to research and expanding
uh our knowledge across a very broad
range of disciplines from engineering to
the social sciences to the humanities uh
to agriculture Etc
um and and and so I'd like you to think
a little bit about
seeing yourself and one of my colleagues
likes to use this phrase phrase and
Anjali kind of suggested it as a scholar
practitioner every situation is
different you can learn a lot from books
and lectures and homework assignments
and things like that but but it really
when you use those skills the techniques
the methodologies the Technologies to
really understand what's going on in
your specific situation in the
organizations you're working with to
identify problems evaluate Solutions uh
that's really taking that discovery
component of our mission seriously so
I'd encourage you to think about uh you
know data and information and evidence
and how to collect it and how to
evaluate it as really a part of what you
do whatever your role is and you'll be
honoring that
Discovery mission that we try to
emphasize at Purdue the next one is this
notion of learning uh certainly you've
already demonstrated your commitment to
personal growth and professional
development and learning uh through the
programs you you've been taking but that
doesn't stop here it's a lifelong
process you should think of it there's
always new advancements new
circumstances and continuing to hone
your skills uh is is really a critical
part of it and that learning Mission
also sort of implies the teaching
component don't
don't overlook your ability to mentor
and guide others so as academics we like
to think about you know how can I share
the insights I've gained uh with others
and use every opportunity you can to
share your Insight experience and
education with those around you and then
the last component is engagement we used
to call this service but and I think
that's sometimes easier uh to identify
with but how can you use what you've
discovered and what you've learned to
solve problems that are really important
and interesting uh whether it's within
your organization or even Beyond but an
Engaged uh scholar
practitioner is someone who really is
driven to improve the community around
them however you define that for you and
that's a mission of Purdue University as
well and it's also something you might
think about how is my work providing
service that's meaningful
so we think this is just the beginning
of great things for you we're proud that
you chose to work with Purdue and simply
learn as a part of that mission I'd like
to congratulate you again and also show
respect to family and friends who've
supported you through these efforts as
well at your sacrifices also the
sacrifice of others around you and we
want to acknowledge that so
congratulations on this fantastic
accomplishment and we look forward to
seeing what happens for you next
thank you Professor for your insightful
remarks thank you so very much
I would now like to take this
opportunity
to introduce achieve guest for this
event
a chief product officer at simply loan
Mr Anil is a seasoned product leader
with a remarkable track record of over
20 years in building Innovative products
across diverse Industries
Mr Anand expertise as a product leader
stands various Industries and product
types highlighting his adaptability and
versatility
throughout his career Mr Anand has also
made notable contribution at renowned
companies such as Dell and National
instrument his deep understanding of the
product development life cycle and his
ability to navigate complex challenges
have consistently positioned him as a
trusted leader in the industry
we are honored to have Mr Anand among us
today
I request you to kindly share a few
words with our participants today
thank you Anjali and I realize I should
come to these more often because I think
the the introductions are super glowing
from the introductions I don't deserve
uh but this is about the Learners today
so let me just uh you know start by
saying
um being the person that actually
creates these programs and has the teams
that create these programs I can tell
you honestly I am absolutely amazed that
you all have completed that you're
persevered through the last few months
and your families have supported you for
such a long time to actually attend you
know two three long sessions every week
and you know getting through these very
very complex programs it's so many
difficult use cases case studies
problems that you have to solve
separately right so I want to First Call
out you have achieved some something
which is beyond learning you're proven
to yourself that you can do this and
that feeling of accomplishment has to be
something that you take away from this
program with you that's what the first
takeaway is keep that sense of you know
I can accomplish this and I can achieve
this with you because you guys are all
winners yeah that's a very important
thing to take away the second thing is I
will talk about this in a minute look
around the room look at the people that
are there connect with them and make
sure that you stay in touch with the
folks that are you know part of this
alumni group these are absolutely
brilliant Achievers all around you and
we'll talk about who these people are
and you know what kind of backgrounds
they come from but this is the network
that you've built here so you're walking
away with a great learning experience
you're walking away with a great
certification from one of the most
premier universities Purdue uh by the
way Purdue is a university that I had
admission a long time back so it's a
very uh font school for me uh one of my
you know in a part of my history if you
may uh but I think the other part is a
network that you're going to be building
out of this group of students that have
actually been here so with that said let
me let's go and look at who are these
you know what these peers that you are
actually with
so the first thing is if you look at a
breakup here you know Professor Bart
actually talked about data you'll find
that you know business analytics data
analytics data engineering data science
and AI That's a big swath of the folks
over here and for you folks there is no
choice you know data you're no data
experts you have to use these tools that
you've learned to make sure that you
apply this in your real world and
deliver value for the companies you work
for and you know for any projects that
you take on look use the learnings that
you have taken out of these programs and
apply them show them that you can do
these things right for the folks who are
in digital marketing digital Supply
Chain management or digital
transformation well like it or not data
is there to stay as well right it's
going to be a big part of how you
measure your own success and your
project success so make sure that this
data aspect that our professor talked
about is part of the story here so first
of all very broad representation of
students from various different
backgrounds
and you know capabilities that are here
in this room and by geography this is
actually a very Global program right so
if you look around you'll find that
there are folks RW sat for rest of the
world so we've got about 12 of the
Learners that are scattered across the
world we've got folks from the US from
India this is a truly Global program as
you can see from the mixed nuts here so
first of all take a step back realize
that you're an absolutely amazing
company and absolutely amazing global
company here in this in this forum here
yeah
the other thing that I wanted to call
out is recognize that the kind of
Learners that are here in this group are
highly qualified you'll find that pretty
much everybody here has some level of a
qualification in fact if you look at it
there's even a small slice that is phds
right so there are some doctors here
um there are many many people with a
master's degree already there are many
with a bachelor's degree so if you're
thinking was this time well spent you
know first of all take a step back and
then look at the kind of people who've
actually been taking these programs
highly accomplished and highly
meritorious people who are here in this
room so you're in great company these
are people who are highly accomplished
and they're taking these programs right
so congratulations you're among those
winners who have actually been able to
make it to the Finishing Line I know
there's one graphic that doesn't show up
here but I'll just you know word word
you know sort of walk walk around it you
know you'll find that about 10 of the
people that are here in this room have
about zero to three four years of
experience here the vast majority 80 to
90 of the Learners that have graduated
here today have eight plus years of
experience so the first thing I also
want to call out is the kind of
experience that is here today combined I
think it'll be like hundreds of
thousands of years of experience
combined here
um and that's again really really
important as you you know Savor this
moment of success realize again that
this pure group is a very highly
experienced group and highly
accomplished group and that's a super
important thing so please connect with
each other make sure that you're you
know these these bonds don't uh you know
separate out after this cohort is done
yeah but those very few words I want to
stop here and say again congratulations
what an absolutely amazing achievement
in the next few minutes you know Anjali
and the team are going to walk you guys
through you know there are a few folks
who did some pretty extraordinary things
during this program
um we'll walk through some of these
extraordinary achievements as well
congratulations everybody and all the
very very best for everything that is
yet to come which I know is absolutely
going to be amazing for you thank you
thank you very much Alan for sharing
this knowledgeable insights thank you
very much
now it's time to recognize and celebrate
the individual accomplishment of our
graduates I along with my colleague
mohini will announce the name of our
graduate spy program we apologize in
advance in case we mispronounce your
name
so moving to the first category of
program which is postgraduate program in
data science I would like to
congratulate amine
congratulations everyone
foreign Iman the same Chris Minish
Chinese
congratulations everyone next we have
Journey Supriya just mean Jaya John
Jyoti Chaudhary Nilesh jism
Kumar Rakesh Randal and Rashmi
congratulations everyone next we have
Ram Krishna Rohit Singh Sajid Ahmed
satyendra Kumar sejal Shafi Shruti silja
Rakesh swapnil Mishra swabnam vashini
congratulations everyone
last but not least we have harisha
stanislava lopamudram
Christine
congratulations to each and every one of
you
before we move on to the next program I
would like to invite akshita from the
participants who would like to share our
experience with all of us can we please
move out to the panelist
akshita you are now moved to the
panelist you can please send me to
yourself and turn on your video
can you hear us
hi hello hi everyone I am Audible
yes you are Audible
yeah
well first of all congratulations
congratulations everyone who uh who
joined the session with me uh I have
been working with the sales and
marketing team from last seven plus
years I wanted to switch my career in
data driven profile uh so I came to know
about the simply Run for the data
science course uh one of my uh
one of my colleagues who suggested me uh
simply done the syllabus and the
teaching method is of the faculty are so
easy and so uh driven to like a study
and it's very comfortable to learn after
the 11 years of study Gap faculty are
super supportive and give us a solution
as soon as we post a doubt on the our
community uh it's been an amazing
experience an amazing journey uh so far
thank you thank you so much thank you so
much akshita for sharing your experience
we are glad you had a wonderful
experience thank you thank you very much
the next category belongs to
postgraduate program in digital
marketing in digital transformation we
have changed
ayush husni sridhar Dr sumanth kalpana
Marcelo Neha sayali and bhargavi
congratulations to all of you
Siddharth Kiran archana Vivekananda
Vishal surajit Vikram Bharat and sujada
congratulations to all of you
Asim Maria Ajit Akila Akshay aluk Aruna
Ashish Dr ayanda
balasubramanyam bhargav Anuj dulari
Faris shalab Gayatri Joshi sharmila
Janine and sugar congratulations to all
of you
congratulations to all of you
Varun
Natasha files navinder
samajeeti Curtis Muhammad salik Ajay
Tanya rishta Gita kalyani
congratulations to all
the Achievers before we move on to the
next program I would like to call Mario
Agnes to the panelists to share her
experience with all of us today
hello Maria you have now been moved to
the panelist please unmute yourself and
turn on your video while you speak
audible to you
but are you there
we can move on
we'll give her a chance
looks out to the same technical issue no
issues we'll take it if she join us
all right so now moving on to our next
program which is for all achieving
programs in data analytics
and I would like to congratulate
congratulations to all of you
congratulations
next we have nikhila Kushi Abdul Anjali
Elise
Ashley
congratulations to all of you
next we have hush mama
Kunal Christiana
Lori Melissa minisha
congratulations everyone
foreign
congratulations to all of you ishan
Nelson Priya Aisha rajendra Keri abhinav
and Daniel congratulations to each and
every one of you before we move on to
our next program we have rajendra from
data analytics program who would like to
share his experience with all of this
can we please move him to the panelist
you have been now moved to the panelist
please update yourself and turn on your
video while you speak
rajendra if we are audible we have given
you the panelist access please unmute
yourself and speak
please
some technical issue again from rajendra
and no problem we will see if we join
that field let him speak now we'll move
on to our next program and my colleague
take you through the next program
belongs to postgraduate program in
business analysis in this program we
have
Ravi Shankar deepam Aditya followership
congratulations to all of you
this
congratulations to all
congratulations to all of you
next up we have sort of Vishal diori
Prashant panish Ramya shishank
Harish and minhas congratulations to all
the achievers
venue
congratulations to all of you
the page DM Seema okay godson Eva Lana
Gotham prasanna George gobin
piyusha Rajesh Guru rajwik Jamal uddin
ayodhi anupriya Akshay Karan and Neha
congratulations to all of you
khalida
Kiran kaushalya lalitha Catherine ajith
Marshall murli mayur Michael
Basu and jagannathan congratulations to
all of you
pranal
congratulations to all of you
foreign
congratulations to all the achievers
moving on to our next program herology
is in postgraduate program in Ai and
machine learning I would like to
congratulate kaushik Naveen Philip
Harris
congratulations everyone
next we have
asthma Ramesh komal and Trina
congratulations everyone
congratulations everyone last but not
least we have Ernest Josh
congratulations to each and every one of
you
foreign
program in digital Supply Chain
management in this category we have
Martin Kumar Ani showing Anil Chetan
hariharan Ashish congratulations to all
of you
next we have
Kanika Kim
can you please unmute yourself and turn
on your video as you speak
to one and all
uh am I Audible
uh actually uh simply learn has provided
me a very good platform to learn my
skills and upgrade my skills and which
have uh which I will in further
Implement in my career and even I would
like to thank the CEO of Simply learn
Krishna Narayan for providing me this
great opportunity and even I would like
to extend my thanks to the Purdue
University which has provided such a
beautiful and very uh means its value
learning
learning course means I have really
enjoyed this course and really have
learned many things and many tools and
many I have really thankful to all of
the mentors who have conducted conducted
the sessions and
the means everyone are so friendly that
whatever doubts I asked they have
cleared me very nicely and very
fantastically uh at the end I'm very
happy with this post and thank you thank
you everybody
thank you thank you for your generosity
and thank you that you provided us
the opportunity to upskill with your
career thank you so much forward
um if your issues please would you like
to unmute yourself and share your
experience with all of us
you are part of the panelist you can
unmute yourself and go ahead
ability issue is still not fixed
no worries so moving on to our next
category proposed Gadget program in
digital marketing we have manjari Lalita
genoveva
Omar
congratulations everyone next we have
Bella gaurav Karen both
nagasai vasigam saurabh ruchika Rajiv
ijaz
and Tanika congratulations everyone
next we have Jonathan
Rajesh Sarah and Neha congratulations to
all of you
next up we have ajinkya Akash today
and Lena congratulations to all of you
next we have zaiway
couple metal
congratulations everyone next we have
Nikita Nilesh pallavi Mamta Praveen
congratulations to all of you
next we have sudrasana surekha sushma
suyash Tamara
um
Genesis
congratulations everyone last but not
least we have Shabana and Indra Kumar
congratulations to all of you
the next category belongs to
postgraduate program
in data Engineering in this category we
have
congratulations to all of you
congratulations to each and every one of
you your hard work determination and
perseverance have paid off you have
successfully completed your academic
programs and we are immensely proud of
your achievements in addition to the
control of degrees we would like to
acknowledge the exceptional achievements
of a few outstanding individuals
The Scholar award is presented to those
who have demonstrated extraordinary
excellence and have made a significant
impact during their time at our
Institution
the residents of these awards are an
inspiration to all of us
the first category belongs to
postgraduate program in digital Supply
Chain management and the winners are
denied who completed the program with
85.2 percent and harihara who completed
the program with 85.05
congratulations to both the winners
the next category belongs to
postgraduate program in data science the
winners are the same who completed the
program with 88.4 percent and Abdullah
who completed the program in 86.8
congratulations to both of you
the next program we have is postgraduate
program in business analysis the winners
are balasini who completed the program
with 87.45 and ravnagria who completed
the program with 85.95 percent
congratulations to all the winners
the next program belongs to postgraduate
program in digital transformation the
winners are Preeti who completed the
program with 86.8 and who completed the
program with 86.4 percent
congratulations to both of you
the next program belongs to postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning the
winners are Amit who completed the
program with 87.45 and Raymond who
completed the program with 86.55
congratulations to both of you
the next program we have is postgraduate
program in data analytics the winners
are yogesh who completed the program
with 86.7 and Christina who completed
the program with 84.83
congratulations to all the winners
moving on the next category is
postgraduate program in data engineering
the winners are Christian who completed
the program with 81.96 and Adrian who
completed the program with 81.6 before
we move on I would like to call Adrian
to the panelist so that he can share his
experience with all of us today
hi Adrian you have been moved to the
panelist please turn on your video and
mute yourself
hello Adrian can you hear us
18 kindly unmute yourself and turn on
your video while you speak
right
hello Adrian yeah we can hear you okay
you can hear me
okay
um
I'm a solution architect saying
Financial crime
and the initial assault everything is
okay but I didn't find any job so I
looked into into various programs and I
started with with your programming
data engineering
and for me it was over a very an
excellent experience
and time well spent and take advanced my
knowledge and my career for sure
I didn't expect to get the degree for
free so I had to work hard and prepare
myself on the cloud before I could
attend any online sessions and I think
everybody should know that that he has
to work hard on those programs
the right on for all the degree at your
face and say it's done despite my age
I'm getting now inquiries and job offers
thanks to this program and thanks to the
wonderful learning experience so I thank
you all everybody
um
it open also my eyes and the gaps I had
in other areas and I think that's also
something very positive you you came
from this program because you look at
different things not just at this with
look on the side and then you realize oh
that's missing that's missing that's
missing so overall thanks a lot
that's great Adrian thank you for giving
this opportunity to be your partner in
your
upscaling Journey that was great thank
you so very much
moving on the next category belongs to
postgraduate program in digital
marketing the winners are Praveen who
completed the program with 90 and
Shabana who completed the program 89.8
congratulations to all the winners
our next category of award is the
speedrunner award this award
acknowledges the Learners who have shown
remarkable efficiency by completing the
program from start to end in the
shortest duration possible
the first category belongs to
postgraduate program in digital
transformation the winners are killichi
who completed the program in 102 days
and bhagavi who completed the program in
102 days as well
I would like to call kalichi to the
panelists so that he can share his
experience with all of us today
hi kalichi you have been now moved to
the panelist please unmute yourself and
turn on your video while you speak
hi everybody can you hear me
yes yes
thank you so much
um it's an honor and a pleasure to be
here today
um I do a humbly accept the speedrunner
award
uh the recognition symbolizes the power
of Education dedication and remarkable
support that I have received throughout
the journey it is a transformative
Journey for me uh during this program I
personally have experienced personal
growth
um faced a lot of challenges and
achieving breakthroughs I do Express all
my heartfelt appreciation to Port
University
and I simply learn for the commitment
for bridging education and the academy
and the industry thus Visionary
partnership has equipped me and all of
us with the skills and mindset that I
will need to try with this digital era
as we step into the world as graduates
um let us continue to strive for
greatness I will need to create a
positive change and shape a more
inclusive and sustainable future
as a faculty members thank you for
sharing your knowledge
U.S parties and guidance you have
inspired us all to think critically
to challenge the status goal and to push
those boundaries for what is possible
as I conclude I accept the award with
deep gratitude it reminds us of the
immense potential and the impacts we can
all make through knowledge passion and
determination
let us all in the spirit of the spirit
Runner strive for excellence
break barriers on the ship they featured
proven by purpose and innovation
together
that are strong with purpose passion and
Relentless pursuit of greatness thank
you all
thank you thank you for your kind words
it was a it was a great journey
congratulations once again
the next category we have is
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning the winners are Gloria who
completed the program in 130 days and
area who completed the program in one
body parties congratulations to both of
you
the next program belongs to data
analytics the winners are Ajit who
completed the program in 101 days and
Bala who completed the program in 126
days congratulations to all the winners
the next category of God belongs to
postgraduate program in business
analysis the winners are Akshay who
completed the program in 160s who
completed the program in 107 days
congratulations to both of you
next up we have postgraduate program in
data engineering winners are Prashant
who completed the program in 123 days
and Judas who completed the program in
128 days congratulations to both of you
the next program we have is
post-graduate program in data science
the winners are swapnil who completed
the program in 110 days and satyendra
who completed the program in 122 days
congratulations to both of you
next we have postgraduate program in
digital marketing the winners are Tanya
who completed the program in 107 days
I'm ejinkya to compare the program in
121 days congratulations to all the
winners
last but not the least we have
postgraduate program in digital Supply
Chain management the winners and
hariharan who completed the program in
109 days congratulations to both of you
before we move on I would like to call
hariharan to the panelists so that he
can share his experience
you have been now moved to panelists you
can please turn on your video and enjoy
yourself for this week
hi everyone good morning good evening
uh thanks for the opportunity given to
me to be part of this program it's been
a great experience for me especially
from a professional perspective had a
lot of value to uh what I'm doing
currently and it's been a good
experience in terms of being part of
this program learning from the experts
in the industry and it was more of an
interactive and collaborative session
that that actual you know classroom so
and it it's been uh fantastic fantastic
in terms of going through this uh
through this University as well thanks a
lot
thank you thank you Ariel and thank you
for sharing your experience with all of
us
now to our internal team we want to
Express gratitude
for your exceptional efforts and
unwavering dedication
you have gone above and beyond working
tirelessly to ensure the smooth
operation of your program
your commitment to our Learners and
institution has been truly commendable
I would like to extend my gratitude
towards our life class instructors we
have akshita Amit amitendra billing
Muhammad funny and Krishan thank you to
all of you
thank you to all of you next up we have
the Bernadette
Mark meenal
Varun cm manjunath and nagivo thank you
to all of you
moving on I would like to call amitendra
from data science category to share his
experience with all of us
hi I'm at Indra you have been now moved
to the panelist please unmute yourself
and turn on your video while you speak
thanks mohini oh ladies and gentlemen
steam guests and most importantly the
incredible students who have
successfully completed their program
I stand before you today with immense
pride and gratitude As We Gather here to
celebrate this momentous occasion and I
would like to extend my heartfelt thanks
to Simply learn further unwavering
support and commitment to empower
aspiring professionals like yourself
their dedication to provide quality
education and transformative learning
experience has undoubtedly played a
vital role in shaping your journey
towards success and to the remarkable
students who sit before me
congratulations and today marks the
culmination of your hard work dedication
and unwavering determination each one of
you has shown remarkable resilience and
and unwavering commitment to your goals
you have conquered the challenges
Embrace new knowledge and demonstrated
remarkable growth throughout your time
here and as you embark on this new
chapter remember the skills and
knowledge you have gained in this
program have equipped deal with the
tools necessary to make a meaningful
impact in an organization before I
conclude I want to express my deepest
admiration for each and every one of you
and especially simply learn for their
support I hope I have no doubt that you
will go and go on to achieve great
things once again congratulations to the
graduating class may your future be
filled with endless possibilities and
boundless success
thank you thank you for sharing your
kind words with all of us
next up I would like to call
from digital Supply Chain management
category to share his experience with
all of us
hello mohini can you hear me
yes
thank you uh first and foremost I want
to extend my heart well congrat
congratulations to each and every one of
you uh you know your presence here today
is uh kind of an unwavering commitment
to your personal growth your knowledge
and you know the Excellence uh
throughout your journey you know you
have been guided and mentored by uh RS
team faculty uh with the help of Simply
learn and as well as supportive
University and uh they are not just
imparted knowledge but also you know
kind of instilled in the values and some
of the critical thinking and the
creativity and the Integrity you know
their dedication to your success has
kind of played an instrumental role in
shaping your minds and preparing you for
the you know the road ahead uh as you
Embark in this new phase of your lives
it's perpet crucial to remember the
invaluable lessons that you have learned
uh but again uh it's kind of a very
important for us to see uh you know
where we move forward uh again with
respect to the simply then uh for sure
uh as Anand said right there are
hundreds and thousands of experience in
this classroom if you recall and it's
not just that you know I have shared a
knowledge but uh in the process uh there
were a lot of instincts where you know I
have learned you know that is something
uh that I should really appreciate you
all sharing your knowledge and that is
something I will uh definitely take away
uh ad education is equipped with you the
tools to make your difference uh you
know I I implore you to use them very
very wisely uh as as I recall that
success is not something which is
measure solely by material achievements
but uh again it it you know it's kind of
a finding in your passion and uh and
also it is very very uh important to
acknowledge uh you know what we have
going forward uh you know just to
conclude uh it's very very important and
uh you know to appreciate uh your family
members and your friends who kind of
supported and this really shows your uh
you know the dedication towards uh you
know your career or growth or all the
personal matters so thank you so much uh
you know I wish you all the best
thank you thank you so much uh it was
great to hear from you and you correctly
said that quotation
uh they do need the support of other as
well so thanks so much
moving on I would like to extend the
Gratitude towards our Master Class
instructors for data science artificial
intelligence and data engineering
category we have professor venkita and
Sarah thank you to both of you
next up for digital business category we
have Dr Collins Dr Zoo Eric Michelle and
jinju thank you to each and every one of
you next up we have our learner success
managers who were there to help you out
in your sessions and support requests we
have Sanya Aisha 201
thank you to all of you
before I move forward I would like to
call nagendra from the digital marketing
faculty to share a few words with us
can you please move uh nag intro to the
panelist so that he can share his
experience with all of us
you are now being moved to the panelist
please unmute yourself and turn on your
video while you speak
absolutely thank you thank you mohini
and all the folks here am I Audible
yes yes you are okay fantastic so I'll
keep it short
um I know there's like you know you
folks have been on this for a while and
last thing I want to do is a long speech
but a hearty congratulations to all of
you I'm standing here very proudly as I
notice all the Learners who have gone
through an incredible journey to
culminate at this very proud moment and
congratulations to your families too
because
um I I can only imagine the sacrifices
you did to go through all those weekends
because most of the sessions I take are
on weekends so I'm sure that was not
easy and that's something that I'm sure
you had a lot of support from your
family to do that
um this this culmination of Simply learn
and Purdue the platform that they've
created uh honestly I think it every
time I see you folks like you meet with
folks like you interact with folks like
you in class blows my mind because it
brings together minds and like you know
meeting in a way that uh no other
platform I have seen does that
um the kind of learning expectations you
have the kind of learning expectations
that the platforms bring together really
I think is uh something that's unmatched
today
um I've spent a lot of time with many of
you and I've enjoyed all those sessions
all the kind of questions that you asked
to keep me on my toes the experiences
you bring to the table that makes for a
more holistic learning so I I hope
whatever whatever knowledge was imparted
whatever knowledge uh you you one of the
key takeaways you had from this platform
enable you to um Make a Better World
Make a Better Community and like you
know achieve your dreams and aspirations
as well so all the very best and my
heartiest congratulations again thank
you
thank you again I believe it's
everyone's sport the families you
themselves who are being um
attending the weekend sessions so thank
you to you as well and congratulations
to all the Achievers once again before
we move forward now I would like to call
manjunath from data transformation
category to share his experience with
all of us can we please move him to the
panelist
you have been now moved to the panelist
please unmute yourself and turn on your
video while you speak
hello everybody hope you all can see me
and I'm audible to all of you
yes yes you are
thank you very much for confirming first
up hello everybody
good morning good evening greetings my
name is some of you may be familiar and
I'm honored to be here in the capacity
of China or black Mentor Public faculty
for simply love
I'm a data practitioner and online but
simply learn for quite some time and
work with simple Learners trainer public
Mentor Public faculty in many areas and
Flagship programs and particularly in
the areas of exponential Technologies
first up thanks much to Simply learn for
making me pause of their team and
helping me deliver these sessions
seamlessly creating value to all the
aspirants and their Learners alike
so I'm looking forward to many more
years of association with Sabrina coming
to the specifics of today's convocation
when I was asked to be part of this I
was thinking about it and realized and
in fact recognized
many of you tried it through and through
with respect to
putting in the effort artist of the
efforts to learn the hard skills beat
the techniques be it programming with
data analysis what have you
then I realized I must share as a
practitioner having worked in this
industry for quite some time
and actively practicing this for a
living
I thought I'll share some of the
underrated aspects of data science with
the participants
to start with I'm just going to give you
a brief example let's imagine for a
moment you are a detective who is
interested with let's say the problem of
solving or another thing the
uh case that is present to you
nobody could do this but you know what
you've got the access to the clues and
they're hidden in plain sight but only
you can see them how good is that you
have the tools and the skills to analyze
and not just that you have the ability
to interpret and communicate perceively
those Clues and finding the truth behind
the mystery you are not a detective
anymore you are a data scientist and
today you have completed one of the most
sought after challenging and rewarding
programs in the world offered by Purdue
University in collaboration with simply
learn huge congratulations to all the
Learners out there big shout out well
dessert cheers to that
I thought I'd just just shared some of
the Lessons Learned what could you say
if I keep the lessons learned to myself
but to share it in the public domain and
to my mentation the followers alike
my journey has been interesting as a
practitioner and I want to talk and tell
you to some of the challenges and
opportunities that avoid you as you step
into the exciting and dynamic world of
data science
for me data science is neither a skill
nor just a career
it's simply not just a skill and a
career what I mean by that is it is a
way of thinking and it is a mindset
which can have the potential to
transform the world
Dera sense is not just about the numbers
and algorithms as many would think
for my experience I can state that it is
also about creativity and Innovation and
a lot more to do with being curious and
asking the relevant questions
it is highly exploratory in nature and
therefore some of the final aspects and
the nuances that I want to talk about
which is underrated is this make sure
you ask always the pertinent and
relevant questions seek answers from the
data after exploring several
possibilities by Thinking Out of the Box
in this sense I said go beyond the
numbers and also let's say the
algorithms I'll just give you a quick
example to get a feel of what I'm
talking about let's say you're looking
at the feedback of a buyer who has given
the verbose text for the feedback and
the rating in one other column it is
natural being a data smart person that
we all are after having gone through
this journey to gravitate towards the
numeric value let's say the rating is
five on a scale of five Wi-Fi where five
is the highest but you know what those
is subscribing all of the verbose
content but not revealing so much the
number by itself the fire so what I what
I recommend you to do in all such cases
is to go beyond the numbers and
algorithms when I say that what I mean
is look at the verbose text for the
feedback
what is it saying what is the sentiment
what is the emotion behind those words
those are the key contributors for the
business isn't it number is the
subtotal are subsumed online all of that
but it doesn't necessarily tell you the
key factors for improvement so I want
you to think out of the box go beyond
the numbers and algorithms and therefore
look at let's say natural language
processing as the one of the appropriate
algorithms to obtain this contextual
setting to unearth The Not So apparent
insights to bring value to the table and
not for your stakeholders but for you
the parent organization I want you to
take note of such things in the realm of
you getting out there trying to solve
the real world problems
realize when we say data science it's a
highly multi-disciplinary field that is
therefore to say it can never be a
single or a solo sport
I always consider data science to be a
team sport and therefore beyond the
numbers and algorithms you've got to be
looking at what's called collaboration
and communication why is that even
important I'm talking about the emphasis
on the soft skills of the soft Dimension
let me just elaborate to make a point or
two
let's say you're in a cross-cultural
setting which is typically the case in
the distributed environments and also in
the realm of Technology enabled
platforms you work with cross-cultural
people
and therefore empathy is rated higher
than even the technical skills bombing
because at the end of it if you're not
empathetic enough how do you even
understand the problems of the people
and if you're not able to collaborate
and communicate in a cross-cultural
setting what is the good of looking at
the numbers in isolation isn't it so you
got to be dealing with cross-cultural
teams and therefore got to be empathetic
towards people at the end of it make no
mistake as a practitioner I can tell it
for sure and I'm sure you bear me out on
this it is all about solving the
problems of the people and therefore it
is beyond the technology and the numbers
for you and me so I just want to put
these things into perspective
so critical aspect of the data science
project is to deal with the people deal
with the stakeholders deal with their
expectations deal with the risks deal
with mitigating them and deal with
several other aspects of managing the
projects quantitatively
so moving on it's not just about the
data alone when data science when I talk
to people they say it's about algorithms
it's about models it's about data it's
about it's about it
that's been far away from reality I say
that it's not just what you can do with
the data in fact the fundamental
question is to ask what it should do
with the data and therefore being fair
responsible and non-discriminatory is
the natural way to deal with things in
the largest scheme of things if you look
at for example the charge Equity as the
tool that has taken the world based on
the emphatic discussion or the mood
point is around these three dimensions
is it being fair is it unbiased is it
responsible is it non-discriminatory
therefore it's not all about what you
can do with the data it's about what you
should do with the data The Dilemma is
to be clear about what I should do with
the data in a fair and reasonable manner
that's what you should be doing good
when you look at the data sense
intervals so therefore you've got to be
mindful of the privacy concerns the
security concerns of the people at large
and thus these final aspects would keep
you in good stead when you're dealing
with the business problems with multiple
stakeholders so in conclusion if it
sounds like I've taken more time I think
you see the value and and I'll conclude
in a miniature too
data science is more than being the
numbers and algorithms it's many things
about creativity and curiosity for me
empathy he is later highest on the sub
Dimension if I can call that as a skill
or a trade then curiosity a curious mind
can explore an exploring mind can
discover a discovering mind can measure
a measurement can manage that's how data
I look at in the larger scheme of things
so creativity curiosity going behind the
numbers and algorithms and obviously
it's about being ethical and responsible
in what you do these are some of the
hard lessons that many of the programs
don't teach at least I bring to the
table and simply Learning System
grooming some of the folks on the sub
dimensions of it I must acknowledge that
last but not the least your work is so
hard to get here
today we have all gathered to celebrate
it and you should all be proud of your
achievements make no mistake it is no
mean achievement it's the hardest of the
efforts unwavering commitment
right to be on the goal it is multi it
is multi-pronged rigorous evaluation
process that we are talking about by
simply learn for over in the certificate
or completion so to make it on the other
side of the line it's not an easy task
it is definitely worth mentioning and
worth celebrating an achievement
whatever the skills you have acquired I
would reckon would keep in good stead to
Take On The World the world outside is
uncertain indirectly and therefore you
need the skills to navigate the
uncertain territory the skills that is
imported by simply learn is enabling you
to be navigating the literally little
more meaningfully not like shooting in
the dark or not knowing where to go one
of the things one of my professors is to
say simply this if you don't know where
you are going how does it matter which
direction you take so what you to be
directionally getting things right is a
function of what you have learned and
what you have discovered along the
journey okay I want to conclude by call
to action and probably
how can I not come up with a quote with
greatness of them all Mr Albert Einstein
my call to action is simply this
make data sensible calling act on it in
fact it is my second calling to be
honest
you've got to be data smart and you got
to be relevant
for you to be sustaining
jobs in the longer term you've got to be
a compelling proposition compelling
value proposition and remains so for the
longer term let me tell you a personal
experience of working with good and
great data scientists and what
differentiates between the two good data
scientists tend to thrive on the
technical capabilities great data
scientists thrive on continuous learning
so that's the key probably and the
differentiated factor for sustaining the
jobs in the longer term
so remember this is the celebration here
at the Milestone is in a marathon called
data science it is a Sprint that you
have taken and reached this Milestone so
it's only the beginning and my friends
a long way away to reach the goal in the
sense of what you want to accomplish in
data science it is Endless Possibilities
data for me is the potential solution
through endless possibilities and you
can see all our own data is there that
essentially means you could look at
plausible solution if not some possible
it is which are imminent so therefore
constantly keep learning keep evolving
keep adapting look at the latest trends
and make sure you learn the state of the
art techniques and be relevant and you
know what don't stop asking questions
the day you stop asking questions you
are not challenging the status quo the
day you stop being curious you stop
exploring things the day you stop
exploring things probably I would say
only a stupid can say I know everything
and then be complacent so we don't want
to be part of that majority anyways yeah
so be data smart keep contributing keep
learning keep collaborating keep
communicating be ethical responsible and
impactful
as Albert Einstein famously said the
important thing is not to stop
questioning curiosity as its own reason
for existence
thanks for hitting me and your attention
much appreciated congratulations again
on your well-deserved Milestone and
success wishing each and every one of
you all the great success in the world
on your onward Journey
thanks to Simply learn at the end and
looking forward to fruitful Association
and continue to deliver on my
commitments and you can mean you can be
counting on that any which way you look
at any day thanks again and devote to
the host thank you
thank you thank you so thank you so much
for your wonderful insights now before
we move forward I would like to call
Maria Agnes from postgraduate program in
digital transformation to share her
journey with all of us today can we
please move her to the panelists
uh hello everyone am I audible now
yes yes Mario you are Audible okay first
of all congratulations to everyone uh
also I would like to thank the entire
simply learn team for putting a great
effort uh during our course we never
faced any glitches or any uh issues
even if we had to reach out to anyone if
people were readily available and we
didn't have to you know run around
searching whom do we contact and how do
we get it done
uh next I would like to thank nagendra
you know our sessions were in the late
hours but still he made sure the
sessions were very interactive and uh
you know Lively so though we don't get
bored uh so I would really like to
appreciate uh all the efforts you know
it's not it's not uh one person here
it's everyone here uh so I would like to
pursue uh further courses with simply
learn and I also have recommended these
courses to my colleague and friends so
you know they can also take advantage of
uh learning more so I really like to
thank
thank you
thank you Maria thank you for sharing
your experience with us and it was
wonderful to hear you out and I hope you
and everyone the very best in your
future
um moving on I would like to extend my
thanks and gratitude to our team for
faculty and Alignment we have Ashish
Kumar Poonam yadav Vijay mukhi and
Jonathan Raji thank you so very much for
all the trainers that you have aligned
for all the sessions and all the
learners moving on the countless hours
spent brainstorming collaborating and
troubleshooting demonstrate the
exceptional commitment and teamwork of
our internal team their creativity
adaptability and Innovation have allowed
us to deliver an unforgettable
experience despite the challenging
circumstances
to our product team Ankit abhinav Atul
Mohan shivika and Charlie thank you to
each and every one of you moving on to
our content team beshaki Dr anjana
arushi thank you to all of you
last but not least we have our
leadership team who oversees all these
programs we have subhashree chandran
koil Sinha Chaudhary Siddharth
chakrabarti myself mohini talai Nathan
rahulera and my lovely course Anjali
thank you to all of you
your feedback has helped us extend our
reach Beyond boundaries enabling us to
connect with individuals who share the
passion for education and making a
positive difference in the world
whether it's spreading the word about
our programs sharing stories of success
or championing causes close to our
hearts we have Amplified our message and
made a meaningful difference in the
lives of a learner and alumni
on behalf of code you and Cindy learn we
would like to extend our deepest
gratitude towards each and every one of
you thank you for being a part of our
online community and for your unwavering
support we are honored to have you as
ambassadors of our institutions mission
and vision once again thank you for
being part of our online community your
engagement and support means the world
to us together let's continue to learn
grow and make a positive impact in the
digital world
as we are near to the end of this online
convocation ceremony I want to leave you
with a few thoughts graduation is not
the end of your journey but rather the
beginning of a new chapter
as you embark on this new phase of your
lives remember the lessons you have
learned the friendships you have bought
and the experiences that have shaped you
the world needs your passion your
intellect and your determination to
create positive change
as you go out there to dream big Embrace
challenges and make a difference in the
lives of the others lastly remember that
you are now a part of the vast network
of aluminar who have gone on to
accomplish great things
stay connected support one another and
continue to learn and grow once again
congratulations to the graduating
Learners we are immensely proud of each
and every one of you may your futures be
filled with success happiness and
fulfillment thank you all for joining in
this virtual convocation ceremony and
congratulations to all of you once again
thank you very much
thank you everybody bye
thank you everyone